Hi everyone, my name is Justine Tan
and I'm with the IBM Cloud team.
Let’s talk about IBM Cloud Pak for Integration.
More than ever, organizations are looking todigitally transform,
providing their employees
with secure and timely access to relevant data
and empowering them to make
better business decisions.
But before they can innovate, they need to
connect all of their data and applications,
while at the same time minimizing their
exposure to business and security risks.
Unfortunately, traditional approaches
to integration are slow to implement,
hard to scale, and requires
skill-intensive, complex technologies.
Organizations need to accelerate integration
with a new agile and AI-powered approach, one
that offers specialized integration capabilities
and enables extended teams to create integrations,
leverages a complete set of integration styles
and capabilities, and embeds AI and automation.
Enter IBM Cloud Pak for Integration, a
comprehensive, hybrid integration platform
that leverages AI-powered automation across the
integration lifecycle to improve use cases like
natural language-powered integration
flows, AI-assisted mapping,
API test creation, anomaly detection,
as well as workload balancing.
In addition, you can accelerate development
of integrations by re-using assets that are
published to the asset repository and by
leveraging built-in smart connectors.
Achieve the optimal mix of legacy and new system
development, modernizing core applications to be
cloud-native and unlocking the value of your data
and services while sun-setting other systems.
Bringing together the industry’s most
complete set of tools and capabilities
and enhancing them through automated deployment
eliminates the expensive maintenance downtime
and multiple licensing fees that accompany other
vendor offerings or “roll your own” approaches.
With IBM Cloud Pak for Integration, we’ve seen
companies speed their integration development by
300%, reduce their integration costs by over 33%,
and increase their overall operational efficiency.
All while maintaining enhanced
security, governance, and availability.
Contact us to learn more about how we can help you build IBM Cloud Pak for Integration
into your business strategy.
As always, be sure to subscribe and stay tuned for more videos like this in the future.